hey everyone persia here and i am joined
by matt o'driscoll
from turtle rock studios he's the lead
producer and working on back for blood
we saw some awesome pvp trailers that i
definitely want to dive into
so thank you so much matt for joining us
and talking about it
uh no worries uh happy to be here
excited to talk about pvp
uh with you it's been a huge thing
amongst a bunch of my friends constantly
asking what's pvp gonna be like
so seeing it has been really exciting
and i definitely have some
some questions i want to shoot your way
starting with the deck building system
is that going to be incorporated into
pvp at all because it's definitely one
of my favorite things
that i tried out in the alpha you're
gonna have in pvp you're gonna have
preset decks
um so there might be a deck yeah so
there might be a deck for like making
yourself assault or medic
or things like that but all the cards
for um
pvp are going to be preset that you
choose from so there's no you're not
going to
earn new ones or gain an advantage some
of the cards have
do have some tuning over pve
uh just slight balance changes so a card
you might get in pve
say for example gives you a health boost
of 200 i'm kind of making these numbers
up a little bit
uh the pve card might give you 250. it's
just
little balance changes that we've found
we've had to make over development but
yeah the cards
uh you won't be building new decks as
such or earning cards you'll be
given a set amount of cards are there
any cards that
are specifically towards the ridden
because i know all these cards are
obviously
for our main characters but what about
the written so if you're going to play
as the ridden in pvp
it's actually a different system that we
have we're calling it the
zombie mutation system zms
so what happens at the start of a round
uh you're granted some points
for the for the zms and so you can put
those points
into different abilities uh depending on
which song uh ridden you've decided to
play
um so we have so uh for example we have
offensive defensive and utility
so let's say you like playing
uh you like playing eureka and perhaps
the exploder variant
that ridden rushes in and he blows up
right and then you've got to respond
so it's like well what do i want to do
like what would be to maybe the best
scene to put my points into
um so for example probably a damage
assault right because then
as you're going to go in you're going to
max out do more damage than you would
before
and help out your team and so it's a
different kind of system
um and each round you have time to
adjust that you gain more points per
round
uh we grant more points each round
depending on how long you've been
playing for
actually how well you're doing we kind
of grant a few more points as well so
yeah each time you have some time to
adjust
and if i can i'll just touch a little
bit on what happens
with the cleaners as well um pre-round
because they also not only do you have
the cards but while
uh the ridden are selecting their
mutation points and making themselves
into
bigger and better killing machines the
cleaners have a certain amount of time
as well and they can look around the
arena
and we've kind of scattered crates
everywhere and in those crates you're
going to find
different weapons different pickups
different
throwable items utilities upgrades that
kind of thing
so there's these two things that are
happening pre-round where do i make my
put my points
if i'm playing the ridden what can i
find and how can i quickly tell
my teammates over here there's a crate
full of cool weapons and so
yeah there's this there's this balance
on both teams as they're about to start
around something that stood out to me
right away was definitely
an eye on strategy because you touched
on it a little bit before
about the different variants of all of
the ridden which is super cool
because i feel like each one gives every
player a chance to kind of identify
their play style and
not really forcing you to pick one or
the other but if you find something
that you like to play as and there's
definitely some variety there
so can you talk to us more about the
varieties of the ridden
you're kind of hitting now on the head
there is there is a lot of variety there
you got to be able to play
as the rika the stinger or the toolboy
and then each one of those has its own
variant
as well um for example the toolbar has a
bruiser variant so one of his attacks he
just kind of comes in with a big club
big club and he's like bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang
actually just like whack-a-mole on
cleaners heads almost
uh and so it's up to you what your kind
of play style
what you enjoy doing um i personally i
really like playing as a stinger
she kind of like hides up amongst the
roofs looks down at where the cleaners
are
trying to get them with the stinger
attack to pin them pin
cleaners in place and then that gives a
chance while you know clean is stuck in
place
perhaps one of the bruiser comes in and
bashed or the like i said the exploder
before
and so it's going to be i think people
are going to start to choose
and try the different variants and
trying out the different
zms points that they can put into each
different variant
and they're going to find they're going
you know it's going to be a little bit
of experimentation what they enjoy
playing as um but i think also on the
cleaner side it's a similar thing right
if like i like playing
as mum for example she's got a
quick revive super helpful like boom
you're up right so
it's like do i like playing out
character she's a like more of a
supporting character
or do i just want to get in there and
like start blasting
ridden's heads limbs and legs off and
all the rest of it
and that's uh maybe walker would be like
a more fitting
for your play style but yeah like you
said plenty of variety
uh in there so we have different
strategies for each side obviously the
cleaners and the britain
and the pvp mode that we saw a trailer
of specifically was swarm mode
i already thought a lot about
strategy between both teams obviously
combos you can do like you mentioned
pinning someone down and then you know
maximizing on that
but there's also a time limit right so
the first round
you have to set the time the next round
you switch slides and you basically have
to beat the time
what is the maximum time limit does that
just go forever or
how does that work yeah we're kind of
still tuning a little bit of that to be
honest with you like are we going to max
it out do we just let it keep going
forever i mean there's so many things
that
happen in a round that kind of force the
time to end why actually
you mentioned swarm mode the reason it's
called swarm mode is yeah there's like
these mutated
insects that are kind of like constantly
coming in and in and in and in so
you know as you get to the later rounds
cleaners and ridden
are much you know in a much tighter uh
tighter space so that kind of speeds up
uh around there
but certainly yeah we've got pvp is
going to feature in our
open beta that's coming out in august
and so
we're going to look at stuff from that
and it's stuff we can look at in tune
and how we think about um
how we think about those working out
those timings as we go forward so we're
not
set in stone yet but it's we have a lot
of chance to look at things as we're
moving forward in
dev awesome and for anybody watching
make sure you pre-order because you're
going to be able to get some access
to that beta so don't forget
and another question i had about pvp in
general
there's a ton of strategy involved with
this game i'm not gonna lie when i
played the alpha with my friends
we spent quite a few times trying to
beat it because we really had to
think and strategize is the game gonna
be affected by maybe leavers or
people who quit early are they going to
be maybe substituted with a.i
or maybe another person matchmaking can
pop in
in pve if a player drops a bot comes in
in pvp right now we don't have it as a
bot comes in
but i think we get it still something
we're looking at and still saying we're
working out what's the best way of doing
it rather than end of match
that would be clumsy so i think it's
certainly stuff that we're still
again we're still tuning and developing
so yeah i get it yeah
players drop in is always always a pain
right but why we hope
i mean these matches they're kind of
short you know maybe 20 minutes to do a
round
the best of three you know they're short
they're engaging there's a lot of change
there's a lot you know it's not like oh
we're not we've lost
we've lost hope here we're not gonna
we're not gonna be able to win this
match there's things that can easily
sway it either way
and so you know hopefully you don't get
too many drops people are gonna stay and
keep playing until the end yeah so what
about
custom modes can maybe me and seven
other friends hop into something
together
no not at launch so for pvp it's gonna
be
uh you're gonna have to team up with
three of your friends and choose
you know where you choose your player
cleaner then you'll play written then
you go back to cleaner or vice versa
yeah but we won't have a custom matches
available at launch
no problem because i'm gonna play it
regardless and i already have all my
friends excited and
we're kind of lamenting on the ls we
took in the alpha and strategizing for
moving forward
so are there any cool strategies maybe
you can
bless me and my friends with at least
about how to
maybe approach pvp some team wombo
combos or
any strats you can lay us on i think in
uh
pvp particularly yeah it's like
you get you got to get together right
you've got that pre-round time start
talking to each other right what are you
loading up with uh with your zms like
are you taking
you know too much too much health buffs
or utility buffs or i need we need more
power to take out the cleaners quicker
it's a it's going to be a lot of that
right a lot of stress on the fly
strategizing i think depending on how
round one went well how you feel you
should go into round two
try and think about which which ridden
you want to take which rhythm
complements the other ridden compared
you know
if we're all going in with tall boys so
yeah i think it's a lot i think it's
going to be a lot of on-the-fly strategy
that you're going to find how this game
plays out which i think is cool
right it's like how does this how did it
change this group of players chose this
set of cleaners
how do we react to that on the ridden
side what upgrades have they got like
how
what weapons are they using it's all
it's going to be a lot that kind of
thing what map is it on you know how
many tall buildings there are versus
like nozzle buildings and how you know
the
swarm coming in and how that affects the
map area
there's yeah it's there's a ton of stuff
going on a ton of cool stuff for people
to strategize over
i'm definitely looking forward to it and
for
anybody else who's looking forward to it
which i know that you all are it is
dropping on october 12th but like we
mentioned earlier
do not forget that you can pre-order and
get access to
the open beta on august 5th that's like
almost
two whole months more than two whole
months before the game so
definitely it's not far at all and oh i
get the tingles just thinking about it
i'm really really excited
all right matt one more question before
you go because i need to know more i
need to get my hands on this game
give us all the details on the open beta
that is coming this august
okay yeah we have early access for the
open beta which is goes from
5th to the 9th of august uh if you
pre-order the game
you have access to that then it becomes
open for everyone uh from the 12th to
the 16th
of august we're gonna have pvp
in there and uh pve you know a selection
of cleaners selection of ridden
um you know it's it's a small amount of
content compared to the full game but
there's
still a lot there to play and we're
gonna it's gonna be great for us as a
developer it's going to be time for us
to see what comes in how people's play
styles bugs and things that we might
need to look at and that's going to just
help us
really polish up and firm up our launch
when we come to october
nice oh my gosh i'm so excited thank you
again
so so much for talking with us and
answering all my questions i know i was
throwing a lot at you but
oh it was great to know even more about
back for blood and i truly cannot wait
to play
yeah it's been great bev thanks for
thanks for giving me the opportunity to
answer these questions and yeah
everyone keep an eye out we're coming
back for blood
[Music]
so
you